в межах
проекту у межах проекту а а для
підтримки реформ ппто в Україні Отже
програма семінару перед вами ми маємо
чотири доповідачі і доволі щільний
графік ви можете задавати свої питання в
чаті або наживо наприкінці семінару в
нас передбачений синхронний переклад ви
бачите на панелі кнопку з українською
мовою будь ласка оберіть її
одночасно відбуватиметься запис семінару
з подальшим його розміщенням на
офіційному YouTube каналі мон і Якщо у
вас буде зацікавленість ви зможете
переглянути семінар у запису а також
повідомити своїх колег про таку
можливість з радістю передаю
слово з радістю передаю слово
генеральному директору директорату
професійної освіти
украї для привітального
слова Добрий день шановні колеги Вітаю
Катерину ну перш за все перед тим як ми
почнемо сьогоднішній вебінар Я б хотіла
звернутися до всіх наших колег які
долучилися сьогодні до вебінару і
нагадати трошки правила поведінки в
онлайн Шановні колеги вас зараз нас
зараз з вами 253 учасника ми спеціально
зробили широке коло учасників тому що
хотіли щоби максимальна кількість
фахівців наших педагогів змогли
долучитися і почути власне вивчити
досвід
використання інструментів з
онлайноцінювання як їх інтегрувати в
освітній процес власне як можна
інтегрувати на власні освітні платформи
для того щоби проводити більш ефективно
навчання дистанційно та і проводити
відповідно
оцінюваннячів освіти Отже Я продовжую
чути ще когось вертаюся до вас все ж
таки слідувати правилам поведінки в
онлайні і дуже прошу зараз всіх
перевірити свої мікрофончики і вмикати
їх тільки за необхідності таж також хочу
нагадати
що відповідно до правил
поведінки в онлайні було доцільно щоби
ви правильно
підписувалися як учасники
а мали різні подекуди і ієрогліфи і
завжди могли
ідентифі учасників Шановні колеги ми все
ще продовжуємо чути тих хто
підключається пані Світлану доприклад
пані
Марію тому в мене будь ласка до вас
прохання все ж таки максимально зараз
послідкуйте за своїми мікрофонами А
друзі отже як було анонсовано Ми
сьогодні
матимемо презентації з досвіду наших
колег фінських колег з якими ми
працювали в рамках програми for Skills
де було реалізовано 20 онлайн-курсів на
нашій платформі профосвіта онлайн
а також ми продовжили з ними співпрацю е
за допомогою інших наших партнерів
організації Fin Church a і я
власне
Ми плануємо такими кращими практиками
нашої співпраці оскільки вже всі курси
переїжджають як ми кажемо на основну
платформу також розповісти вам про те
які інструменти використовувалися під
час цього оцінювання і як можна ці
інструменти застосовувати у вас в
освітньому процесі не буду дуже
затримувати час ще раз хочу подякувати
нашим партнерам за відкритість за
ініціативність і Катерино пані Валентино
ми вас чуємо Катерино передаю вам слово
дякую Ірина Дуже дякую за вас за ваш як
завжди гарний виступ О І так Ви всіх
підбадьорюєте настроюєте на такий гарний
лад Ось і хочу сказати що ви дуже
детально розказали про нашу співпрацю
але по факту дійсно ні цього семінару ні
проекту не було б без наших шановних
партнерів Міністерства освіти і науки
України Так
що давайте
продовжувати я пере Даю слово
генеральному директору omnieducation
partnership Ltd рві Янн яка розповість
про ключові методологічні аспекти
онлайноцінювання merві Turn
please Катерино може нагадаємо нашим
учасникам що треба обрати собі переклад
Просто може ще не всі знають тактак хто
під'єднався пізніше будь ласка на панелі
внизу обберіть е українська мова ви
бачите є вибір саме українська
мова Хочу повідомити що в нас вже
учасників за цей
часk You youat and you ir de Friends
шановні українські друзі наскільки
приємно мені всіх бачити вас онлайн це
тема для нас надзвичайно важливо
Оскільки ми знаємо що Світ змінюється і
продовжує постійно
змінюватися так сподіваюсь що ми
вирішили проблеми зі
звуком оці світові
мегатренди які сьогодні становлять
виклики по всьому світові у нас
наприклад є зелений перехід і найбільший
другий тренд - це цифровізація як ви
бачите на цьому слайді цифровізація
означає що ми як учителі як провайдери
освіти Ми маємо тепер перейти в іншу
зону комфорту я не хочу говорити вийти з
зафу зону комфорту тому що я вважаю що
сьогодні це вже є частина нашої зони
комфорту але в цифровізації постійно
щось виникає це не є щось усталеним і Я
впевнений що ви як освітяні
фахівці Ви маєте дійсно все зрозуміти і
е засвоїти перш ніж е переходити
на нові технології і ця історія не
змінюється і вже не може таке бути що
вчитель навчає тому що він знає вже і ми
маємо тут запровадити підхід навчання
впродовж життя у сфері цифрових
технологій З тим щоб не лише встигати за
тим що відбувається а бути проактивними
як освітяни як працівники освіти і що це
означає на
практиці я хочу для себе відкрити
світлай англійською мовою Отже сфери
цифрової
компетентності професійній освіті тут у
нас є дві сторони медалі У нас є
педагогічний аспект і у нас також є
адміністративний аспект з кожним
інструментом з кожною платформою є
адміністрування і це все має рухатися
пліч-упліч тому що дуже часто лідери
керівники вчителі учні студенти вони не
на стороні адміністрування У нас є
окремо адміністратори і без діалогу Вони
не будуть розуміти педагогічний аспект
Тому потрібно і важливо працювати
разом будь ласка
мікрофони своє е-е вимикайте Отже коли
ми говоримо про цю таку велику картину
розвиток і інновацій постійно додаються
нові речі і ми повинні дійсно мати таку
жагу до знань але також бути критичним
Що це саме те що підтримує навчання і
наше дійсно справжнє оцінювання
компетентностей тобто де якісь штучки
які просто відкривають нові можливості
не мають сенс тобто є такий критичний
вимір і думати чи це дійсно якимсь чином
додасть цінності до процесу навчання
оцінювання також є аспекти управління
даними і безпека ми знаємо що
кібербезпека є великим питанням з тим
щоб Дані були захищені це частина
адміністрування в цьому рівнянні ми
маємо дивитися на різні системи
оцінювання немає якогось універсального
рішення і на жаль якщо ми навіть би
розробляли онлайн-тести для всіх це не
буде рішенням ми маємо дивитися на
цифрове оцінювання з більш такого
холістичного погляду і також світування
які дані ми
можемо одержати І що ми пропонуємо тому
що великі дані можуть бути доволі
цікавими Вони можуть показувати де є
багалини в навчанні і де ми хочемо
удосконалити
ее з тим
наприклад інтерфейс для користувачів як
загалом навчання надається з тим щоб це
було максимальної якості Звичайно Це
також
дозволяє залучати і комунікувати онлайн
тобто це має бути командна робота тому
це співпраця
особливо у нас є
система управління навчанням в
міністерстві тому має сенс співпрацювати
далі забір і підбір матеріалів і
ресурсів це також забирає доволі багато
часу це означає що
роль учителів педагогічного персоналу
змінюється Ми також маємо думати про
навчання в форматі онлайн і на
вставництво Отже коли йдеться про онлайн
оцінювання цифрове оцінювання Я думаю що
варто зробити крок назад і подивитися на
таксономію Блума це те про що ми маємо
пам'ятати коли ми розробляємо
інструменти цифрові інструменти івпраці
або вбудовуємо їх свої курси і дивитися
загалом на оцінювання тому що оцінювати
це не лише те що відбувається наприкінці
курсу це те що відбувається постійно
якщо ми концентруємося на
запам'ятовуванні то це найнижчий рівень
таксономії Блума і це недостатньо для
майбутніх фахівців і для розвитку їхніх
компетентностей ми маємо фокусуватися на
розумінні застосувані навіть на аналізі
тому що зрештою ми могли б розробляти
таке навчання яке є
затребуваним від працівників на ринку
праці звичайно і оцінювання і творчість
це вже на найвищих щаблях
але на жаль дуже часто ми перевіряємо
лише наскільки учень щось пам'ятає цього
недостатньо навіть для
розуміння застосування та
аналізу то
Тобто
ми маємо робити кроки з тим щоб
оцінювання мало сенс з точки зору
професійних
компетентностей коли ми дивимося на
деякі переваги і деякі виклики коли
йдеться про онлайно оцінювання як процес
або якийсь одномоментний захід це все
про досвід користувача
ми маємо в центр поставити здобувача
освіти Чи особу яку навчається дуже
часто піднімають питання про надійність
наскільки ми знаємо що саме ця
особа яка складає тест онлайн Чи виконує
завдання як нам
ідентифікувати учнів здобувачів освіти в
нашому досвіді у нас наприклад були
відео які показали компетентності від
наших партнерів в єскріпці на початку
кожної демонстрації ми просимо людей
Включити камеру себе представити Ось я
ее є таким Ось моє посвідчення особи
наприклад паспорт тобто на початку ми
бачимо саме посвідчення особи і якщо
немає когось хто перевіряє на місці тому
що є різні способи адміністрування
оцінювання онлайн але ми маємо також
бути свідомі цього і вбудовувати ті
елементи щоб забезпечити дійсно
надійність оцінювання в плані того що ми
чітко знаємо хто проходить з іншого боку
це дуже економічно ефективно і людям не
потрібно наприклад переїжджати тому для
екології це дуже корисно
і дуже зручно
масштабувати і можна одночасно проводити
оцінювання для великої кількості і я
хочу сказати що це
стосується деякі частини Ми не говоримо
про те що все перевести онлайн але
потрібно критично до цього підходити і
подумати які
елементи добре підходять для
онлайнооцінювання і як ми маємо це обє
знати з практичним навчанням Тобто це
змішаний підхід зазвичай є найкращим
далі чи ми оцінюємо знання або
компетентності тут ми повертаємося до
таксономії
Блума які онлайнінструменти ми
використовуємо як ми укладаємо
оцінювання Чи це є процес впродовж курсу
і наскільки вчитель може надати фідбек
Чи це просто якийсь фінальний іспит для
нас критично подумати про це в сфері
професійної
освіти далі часто є такі ситуації і
сценарії коли ми не можемо протестувати
або навіть
е навчати в реальному житті і ми можемо
це використовувати як місток до
промисловості у нас є певні частини
серед довище можна робити відео У нас є
додатки віртуальної реальності і ми
можемо помістити особу в середовищі де
вона побачить як це виглядає це збагачує
досвід і відкриває багато можливостей
дооцінювання учнів в різних сценаріях
Наскільки швидко особа реагує наприклад
е якщо це на будівельному Майдані чику і
ви віртуально переміщаєте в реальному
житті це може бути небезпечно А у відео
чи віртуальній реальності ми можемо це
робити чи особа може визначити що
неправильно тут на цьому будівельному
майданчику що особа зробила по-інше
Тобто ми можемо показувати різні
сценарії в онлайн оцінюванні це те чого
ми раніше не могли робити це прекрасна
можливість але виклик з іншого боку це
означає необхідність технічної підтримки
І що це має бути певна крива навчання
для такого оцінювання тобто тут це
адміністратори адміністрування
і вчителі мають працювати разом Щоб
зробити найкращі рішення для навчання
оцінювання і останнє
це багато користувачв В нас є багато
різних
альтернатив Коли одночасно багато
користувачів можуть робити щось разом у
віртуальному середовищі навіть для
онлайн-курсу У нас є інструменти коли
можна
організовувати реальну співпрацю в
реальному часі між людьми які навчаються
тобто Для нас
це нове і тож що ми говоримо що цифро
досконалість вже насправді стала вимогою
для сучасної професійної освіти це
означає що всі ми маємо нові можливості
але стикаємося із новими викликами тому
я дуже рада що у нас така велика
аудиторія Я вас всіх
заохочую будь ласка використовуйте
матеріали діліться з вашими колегами і
вертаєтеся Я сподіваюсь що цей семінар
буде для вас корисним і Дякую за те що
ви доєдналися і дякую за те що ділитеся
своїми
думками Дякую мерві що ви
сконцентрувалися сконцентрувала свою
увагу саме на сучасних тенденціях
розвитку онлайн-оцінювання та методичних
аспектах і ми переходимо до наступного
виступу тут у нас два спікери це
експерти оп Анна ла та Петрі німінен які
продемонструють вам різноманітні цифрові
інтерактивні
інструменти які можна використовувати
для оцінювання включаючи інструменти
платформи
openedex а Аню Прошу по черзі Анна потім
Петрі Anna First then P Next
please
Отже всім вітання Дякую за те що ви
доєдналися до цього
семінару я зроблю короткий огляд деяких
інструментів які можуть бути
використовані для різні ли для різних
типів
оцінювання а потім Петрі більш детально
розкажеть про системи управління
навчанням що це системи можуть
пропонувати і будь ласка наприкінці
ставте ваші запитання по-перше коли ми
говоримо про
оцінювання є два загальні типи це
підсумкове
оцінювання зазвичай е саме про це
думають люди що це якийсь
тест е як перевірка
знань але це не єдиний вид оцінювання є
так зване формативне оцінювання
це оцінювання яке відбувається впродовж
процесу
навчання Тобто це оцінювання як елемент
навчання під час навчання або під час
виконання якихось практичних завдань чи
вправ коли
учні навчаються і вчи їх може оцінювати
і надавати їм
фідбек і тут є дуже багато різних
можливостей якщо це підсумкове навчання
то це може бути тест
а
для підсумкового оцінювання є сотні
різних
тестів
один з таких ми використовуємо клас
маркер ви бачите приклад на слайді це ви
мо особа може обрати одну правильну
відповідь або кілька правильних
відповідей але що варто більше
обговорювати це саме формативне
оцінювання і як ми можемо це
впроваджувати впродовж
навчання Я знаю що
підсумкові тести також буде
предметом наших подальших обговорень але
наразі давайте подивимося на формативне
оцінювання ми знаємо що сьогодні в
цифровому світі є тисячі різних
інструментів їх настільки багато
вже ми не можемо впровадити абсолютно
все і навіть немає в цьому необхідності
але необхідно мі що вони мають різні
функції тобто
які групи таких інструментів існують тут
я представила і це навіть не все що ми
використовуємо в процесі гібридного
навчання ну є платформи чи системи
управління
навчанням вони можуть включати різні
елементи навчання і мають ласні
інструменти я не буду детально говорити
саме про це але Петрі саме
засередиться На цьому тому що це дуже
таке є дуже багато систем як Model
openedex різні
інші ви можете там створювати
контент завантажувати відео включати
використовувати їх Далі є цифрові
інструменти які підтримують процеси
співпраці Наприклад якщо ми в класі
звичайно ми можемо організувати групову
роботу але якщо навчання відбувається
онлайн як ми можемо створити умови для
того щоб було спільне обговорення або
робота над
проектом
інший варіант це
інтерактивні візуальні елементи
це може бути на
360° це може бути відеозапис якогось
місця і як у відеогри ви можете мати
деякі кнопочки ви можете або дізнатися
ви можете дивитися відео це може бути
якась Понора
середовище наприклад як будівельний
майданчик Далі є певні завдання
Наприклад якщо ми хочемо щоб учні робили
письмове завдання або щось створювали
для цього є цифрові інструменти також є
інструменти
інтерактивні які ми використовуємо для
збору даних чи опитування Це або
запитати швидку якусь думку
Або можна
включити різні елементи для того щоб
показати
сприйняття Наприклад Це або ми наприклад
якщо в класі то учні піднімають руку
Наприклад якщо у нас немає зум-сесії Я
також можу попросити підняти руку
але
є інші способи організувати
це
також важлива частина будь-якого процесу
навчання - це зворотній
зв'язок тому що це показує нам як
відбувається наш процес навчання він
спрямовує навчання це дійсно важлива
частина і навчання і оцінювання звичайно
коли йдеться про
підсумково оцінювання це може бути
якийсь певний бал 60 наприклад зі 100 А
коли ми говоримо про формативне
оцінювання результати мають
підкріплюватися фідбеком і ви як учитель
Як ви можете спрямовувати учня з тим щоб
він показував кращі результати
навчання
тут я показую деякі опції Звичайно це
дуже
обмежено в
кількості насправді їх існує набагато
більше але це просто Для прикладу як я
вже сказала системи управління
навчанням як openedex дуже часто
використовується наприклад у Фінляндії
дуже часто користуються платформою mle
але сьогодні ми поговоримо про систему
openedex і коли я завершу свою частину
тоді Петрі вам більш більше розкажеть
про цю систему І що вона пропонує для
учасників і для
вчителів далі для співпраці наразі Ми
дуже багато використовуємо padlet
це така дошка ви можете ставити
запитання ось тут приклад на цьому
слайді можна поставити запитання і всі
учасники
ставлять плюсики
або цифру ви можете давати реакції
підняти великий палець або
прокоментувати відповідь Тобто це спосіб
обговорення якихось запитань це може
бути відкрите запитання розкажіть про
ваш досвід наприклад ла з чимось
і учасники коментують і це також як
дискусія але не відбувається одночасно
це синхронізоване навчання але у нас тут
є вся дискусія і я можу як учитель
подивитися на цю дошку і
відстежити що обговорювалося на якому ми
етапі
чи
якісь виклики це можна зберегти я можу
це е завантажити як файл після
е з тим щоб я після цього могла
проаналізувати і Можливо щось
скоригувати в своєму навчанні це дуже
простий інструмент багатьма мовами є
різні опції що можна з цим
робити Особисто я дуже рекомендую Але
звичайно є різні варіанти це є
роборд або деякі інші де які дозволяють
структурувати думки
створити такі ментальні карти за
допомогою ключових слів наприклад також
підтримує навчання але оцей рубор - Це
доволі такий складний інструмент і
можливо для учасників для яких це нове і
які не мають таких
потужних it навичок можливо для них це
буде занадто складно але падлет і саме
тому ми дуже часто це використовуємо це
дуже простий дуже інтуїтивний е і
зручний інструмент звичайно ви можете
знайти інший якщо ви пошукаєте є дуже
багато різних
можливостей але ми тут недаємо приклад
падlet тому що ми вважаємо що це дуже
хороший інструмент далі інтерактивні
візуальні
елементи ну наприклад можна мати якесь
зображення У нас ви бачите сердечко
плюсики і коли ви клікнете то
відкривається або текст або
відео і тому Таким чином можна одержати
інформацію це може бути лише
картинка це може бути
відео більш практично орієнтоване
наприклад
ее будівельний майданчик і там різні
елементи і
ее учні можуть потім розкривати різні
елементи і дивитися наприклад відео як
Ці предмети використовуються на
будівельному майданчику і один з
інструментів називається Link який
підтримує такі відео і такі
інтерактивні візуальні компоненти ми
можемо тут створити такий онлайн-курс І
це дуже гарний
спосіб
урізноманітнити презентацію інформації
замість того щоб це був такий довгий
текст ви можете
включити відео або цей такий
інтерактивну
візуалізацію і для учасників це дуже
корисно і зручно особливо тих я цим які
на віддають перевагу візуальному
навчанні ось це ціі три приклади видів
цифрових інструментів далі ще три для
завдань існують різні варіанти Що можна
робити
і дуже багато систем управління
навчанням включають можливості виконати
завдань але якщо немає такої
системи що можливо
це створити такі шаблони PDF куди можна
щось вставляти якщо я хочу щоб учень
щось намалював але подав якусь ідею так
само як і учень би це робив на папері і
я можна використати такі підяв
шаблони там є спеціальне поле де
можна включити відповідь
і тут
необмежений простір і як учитель я
просто скролю і читаю
і це не просто поставити запитання ми
можемо
включити якісь навідні запитання дати
певну структуру тобто включити
ее ті елементи які ми хочемо і показати
взаємозв'язки і учень надсилає або
учасник навчання
відправляє але вони також це зберігають
для себе
і тобто після виконання завдання навіть
вони відправили вони
можуть на якомусь сервері тобто я
постійно маю доступ на своєму комп'ютері
і тому з цієї точки зору це гарний
інструмент ви це заповнили і ви постійно
це маєте з
собою для інструментів опитування це
також для взаємодії з
аудиторією якщо наприклад у нас
онлайнсесія як зараз і в мене група і ми
б хотіли поставити запитання
наприклад що є найскладнішим або
найважливішим або попросити
ранджувати що відповідно до
досвіду можна наприклад використати Zoom
якщо це синхронна сесія в
Зумі наразі є ця функція опитування в
Зумі
але якщо дуже багато учасників то це
неможливо і іноді Ми не можемо
використати зуom іноді це віддалене і це
асинхронне навчання тобто коли кожен
виконує якесь завдання в свій час і для
цього ментимітр дуже
підходить люди можуть голосувати за
різні опції ранджувати Як ви можете тут
побачити І що гарно Це те що результати
відображуються в реальному часі ви
бачите на гістограмі
було запитання різні варіанти і в певний
момент часу ви можете
побачити Хто за яку За який варіант
відповіді проголосував Тобто це не лише
ваша думка ви можете мати велику картину
того що
відбувається загалом в середовищі і це
може бути
також інформація для рефлексії це може
бути відправна точка для дискусії
Подивіться на результати і подумайте
чому тут так багато людей обрали
наприклад цю відповідь Тобто це
інтеракція навіть якщо не відбувається
одночасно але забезпечує таке особисту
залученість і ви можете мати
результати і бачити хто як відповів і ще
у нас є фідбек чи зворотний зв'язок це
дуже важлива частина якщо в класі я можу
відразу надати
фідідбек або
написати в певній
формі для
завдання Наприклад якщо в цьому PDF Я
також можу тут же в
PDF поставити
примітку полі для фідбеку але є окремі
інструменти Я знаю що всі ви вже знайомі
з Google
формами може бути посилання і учні
можуть анонімно наприклад оцінити
курс написати
що їм сподобалося що не сподобалося що
все ще не
ясно І на основі цього можна потім
коригувати навчальні матеріали що ви
бачите що всі незрозуміли якийсь один
аспект чи тему тут можна сфокусуватися
дуже важливий інструмент і ви як учителі
можете
також відправляти фідбек учням наразі ми
використовуємо дуже широко
weброopл як інструмент Це дуже гарний
інструмент створювати різні
опитувальники і може бути дуже навіть
складна структура якщо ви таким чином
відповіли то
тоді воно йде В одному напрямку якщо
інша відповідь То тоді відкриваються
інші питання і це дуже хороша
статистична також частина яка є в цьому
інструменті ви бачите звіт всю
статистичну дану середні показники і як
опитувальник особливо якщо ви робите це
до дослідження Потім після дослідження
хочете що щось дізнатися про вашу групу
учасників дійсно це дуже
корисно Дуже дякую Тепер я прошу
Петрі перейти до другої
і ми Вам надаємо 7
хвилин добре ви бачите мій
екран кілька слів скажу про інструменти
які ви можете використати на платформі
openedк це
е системи управління навчаннями яка є у
відкритому доступу використовується
фінські міністерством дуже популярна по
всьому
світові і вже має дуже багато різної
функціональності
інструментів те що ви Може Вам не
потрібно щось
розробляти і Звичайно є опція
використовувати
інструменти зовнішніх
сторін
я
коротенько розкажу Але це лише приклади
звичайно набагато більше інструментів є
в
доступі деякі вже вбудовані в
openк ну такі
прості як завдання вибору єє правильною
відповіді багатьох dropdу
це надання
відповіді у вигляді цифри чи тексту є
додаткові інструменти які вже вбудовані
в платформу деякі треба просто
акти активувати ви можете попросити ваш
it департамент це Наприклад як
опитування і є додаткові
інструменти третіх сторін тут можливо
потрібні певні технічні навички з тим
щоб їх завантажити і доєднати до
openedex але ви можете
попросити фахівця з it щоб вам допомогти
але дуже багато вже готові це у
відкритому доступі ви можете це
використовувати
це інтерактивна
візуалізація або інструмент який
називається Image Map
Input Ну і звичайно можна за допомогою
скриптів Java чи
python розробляти
індивідуалізовані
складові для цієї
платформи внизу на цьому сладі є
посилання і там ви можете
знайти більше інформації про ці
інструменти ну на цьому
слайді пояснення того які вже є
вбудовані доволі прості інструменти
наприклад завдання чи
задачі де учасник вибирає одну правильну
відповідь а
або учасник має зазначити відповідь у
вигляді числа або
тексту додаткові
інструменти які можливо є або їх
потрібно вмикнути чи
активувати це калькулятор
це такий інструмент Drag and дроп де
можна
перетягувати предмети об'єкти чи
тексти і таке інше є файли Google Drive
є такий інструмент
iframe і тут можна вбудовувати всі
онлайнматеріали у ваш
курс паadlet
mul те що вже було сказано
Анною тобто все що ви можете знайти
онлайн і те що ви хочете використовувати
для ваших матеріалів за допомогою цього
інструменту iframe ви можете їх включити
у ваш
курс
інструменти
зовнішні ну це лише приклади як я вже
сказав це інструмент який можна
використовувати Анна вже сказала як
використовувати зображення з картами це
може бути наприклад фотографія чогось і
ви відмічаєте певні ділянки які потім
розкриваються за допомогою текстів чи
відео Наприклад також є опція
використовувати спеціальні коди для того
щоб індивідуально роз ляти власні
інструменти але можна пошукати в
інтернеті різні безкоштовні інструменти
які можна завантажувати і
використовувати в своїх
матеріалах але це такі вже е більш
складні сучасні інструменти які можливо
потребуватимуть технічної підтримки
фахівців it з тим щоб
м використовувати їх на платформі
важлива річ також і це є вбудована
вбудований функціонал в платформі Open
deex це те що ви одержуєте різні
показники і статистичні дані стосовно
того як учасники
використовують ці інструменти і яка їхня
успішність ви
можете наприклад подивитися скільки
разів продивлялися відео
які завдання наразі
виконуються і це вбудований
функціонал який показує дуже багато
різноманітної
статистики
особливо коли ви використовуєте вправи
задачі ви можете також одержати
статистику про успішність
виконання
і таким чином ви можете
відстежити які інтерактивні вправи
виконуються
чи є якісь проблеми з
розумінням які є типові помилки
ну такого роду
інформація
ось від
мене це все я дуже загально представив
цю тему але хочу сказати що нові
інструменти постійно З'являються і ви
просто маєте слідкувати і дивитися що є
доступним але онлайн є дійсно дуже
хороша інформація про Open і deк ви
можете самостійно більше ознайомитися я
лише вам дав такий за
огляд Дякую за
увагу Анна та Петрі дякуємо вам за
цікаву презентацію і різноманіття
продемонстрували таке різноманіття
корисних інтерактивних інструментів Ми
сподіваємося що ця інформація стане в
нагоді учасникам нашого семінару для
подальшого застосування на
практиці наступна тема в нас фінальне
оцінювання інструменти та загальніреко
ції
мікрокваліфікації bдges доповідач
escoліус з омні еско Я запрошую вас до
презентації Анна щиро дякую Дякую за те
що ви мене
запросили
хочу показати
свою презентацію Я сподіваюсь що вам
видно
Отже я хочу почати з
запитанням
чого навіщо ми оцінюємо яка мета і є три
основні причини ну найбільш Очевидно це
звичайно
контекстуально це те що органи освіти і
провайдери освіти мусять знати які
індивідуальні
компетентності і здобувачі освіти також
повинні
знати що вони здатні робити Які вони
навички мають які не мають і вчителі
керівники Які створюють курси і
проводять навчання вони також мають
розумі ти Як ідуть справи І я сподіваюсь
що моя презентація надасть вам нові ідеї
стосовно цих трьох
цілей В мене є приклади стосовно
навчання
тренерів і це можна поєднати також але
не
обов'язково
Отже я хочу вибачитися у нас слайди лише
англійською мовою але я
сподіваюсь що Ви зрозумієте за допомогою
перекладу Ну перша - це програма
розроблення компетентностей яка вже
см-8сім років запровадження і це
неформальне навчання цифрових
компетентностей для фахівців
е-е які
працюють у сфері професійної
освіти у нас є
спеціальний онлайн є спеціальний сайт
для підвищення кваліфікації у сфері
інформаційно-комунікаційних технологій
для
тренерів і у формі такої ігрової
розроблена програма яка використовує
беджі
компетентностей
при демонстрації навичок відповідно до
певних рекомендацій я згодом більш
детально розкажу про ці беджи і команда
е експертів вони
е
розглядають ці бедви компетентності і
докази ось загальна така картина це
різні беджиі
які одержані одним здобувачем освіти
загалом
45 беджів для різних навичок чи
компетентностей вони поєднані в 12
категорій
це такі
майстербеджі які
надаються і
нарешті якщо о наприкінці
програми вони
одержують такі золоті беджі
кваліфікацій в нас є педагогічні моделі
є інструменти мережі співпраця і це
збагачує загалом середовище
навчання та ж сама структура
використовується і для учнів студентів в
нашому інституті суті є такі невеличкі
беджі які як сертифікати які окремо
здобуваються по кожній компетентності є
метабеджі на метарівні і зрештою коли
особа одержує
бедж є портфоліо де можна побачити всі
ці беджи і їх можна також потім
пересилати
е
відкритий
бедж це така іконка ви можете побачити
що хтось
одержав цей бедж але є повна
метаінформація якщо це лише
сертифікат за участь за присутність там
і буде сказано що особа була присутньою
на такому заході але тут нічого не
говориться про компетентність як таку
якщо це компетентнісні беджі то тоді
будуть критерії і також
докази наприклад цей бедж у сфері
цифрової стратегії тут є критерії є теми
це способи демонстрації конкретних
навичок і перш ніж здобути цей бетж
потрібно
показати дійсно які є компетент
має бути певні свідчення тут скріншот
от це мої докази команда переглядає
аналізує і потім присуджує цей
бедж я одержую
лінк на певний сайт де я можу зава н
тажити цей бетж у своє портфоліо онлайн
і вже я можу поділитися цією інформацією
з роботодавцем чи навчальним закладом
деякі вже мають ці
додатки
API що кадрові системи системи
управління
персоналом вони вже розуміють коли вони
одержують цей бедж що це за сертифікат
що це за
компетентність і такий дуже добре в цій
системі відкритих беджів як роботодавець
ви можете відкрити і
подивитися який практичний зміст цієї
навички які докази того
що ця особа має відповідну компетент
і Є такий спеціальний
онлайнінструмент і є питання до яких ми
повернемося трішечки
пізніше що потрібно враховувати при
використанні цих
беджів але Незалежно від того чи це
бедже Чи це сертифікати ми маємо думати
що це за рамка чи яку рамку
використовувати при розробленні курсу
Зазвичай ми використовуємо Я знаю що в
Україні вже використовується
це європейська рамка цифрової
компетентності для працівників
освіти і ви вже можливо
знаєте що є шість сфер
компетентностей деякі стосуються
професійних компетентностей
працівників
освіти деякі стосуються більш
педагогічних компетентностей а також
компетентності навчання і коли ви
створюєте
курс наприклад з цифрової компетентності
для вчителів професійної
освіти варто
перевірити зміст і навча результати на
відповідність цим сферам оцей інструмент
ЄС має конкретний опис того що включають
ці сфери і Якщо Ви розробляєте свій
курс
е те що добре що ви можете в вже
використовувати готові інструменти
с на сайті
є два інструменти один називається селфі
для вчителів а
другий для вищої
освіти і це інструмент самооцінки або
такої
саморефлексії які
компетентності вчителі мають в усіх
шість
сферах це форма де вчитель надає
інформацію а потім система надає
фіддбек стосовно того які сильні сторони
цього вчителя і де сфери які є слабшими
це вже готовий інструмент і коли
Ви розробляєте такого роду
курси дуже корисно провести таке базове
дослідження вихідногорі
рівня до початку курсу і потім після
курсу з тим щоб
оцінити який одержано
вплив я показую вам приклад з Молдови
кілька років тому ми
розпочали навчання тренерів на основі
цієї рамки цифрової компетентності для
працівників
освіти в
2019 році ми запровадили оцю саму
рефлексію вчителі відповідали на
запитання
наприклад я використовую цифрові
технології з тим щоб спільно працювати з
колегами і вони оцінювали по шкалі
е від нуля до
пяти і після курсу
знову-таки пройшли
саморефлексію і ми бачимо що якщо в
19-му році середній результат був 3,2 то
в 20-му році 4,4 і не лише це
надає людям
ее тим хто бере участь у навчанні
розуміння того який прогрес і що над чим
потрібно попрацювати але і для тих хто
проводить таке навчання і розробляє таке
навчання що потрібно допрацювати Можливо
на чому потрібно
сфокусуватися отже як наприклад
використовувати відкритиі беджи для
такого типу курсів як прив'язати це до
рамки як
використовувати
інструменти з тим щоб зрозуміти який
насправді був вплив на
результати Отже ми це використовували і
з учнями і з самими
тренерами і є два конкретні питання які
ми маємо стосовно відкритих педжів
по-перше як на чому рунтується
надійність і достовірність
беджів існують різні школи різні
експерти які аналізують
переглядають відповідну інформацію для
присудження бепеджів як ми можемо
забезпечити довіру до всієї цієї
системи Тобто це цифрові
сертифікати вони дуже гарно виглядають
як і паперовий
сертифікат
але потрібно
подумати як забезпечити дійсно цю довіру
достовірність і
надійність
навіть якщо Ми впевнені Так ми довіряємо
цим беджам і цим сертифікатам друге
питання яка є
цінність у нас уже є Столітня історія
видачі паперових
сертифікатів або є база даних
Міністерства де ми можемо побачити які
дипломи були видані навчальними
закладами але це система скоріше яка
грунтується на
е третій
стороні Тобто ви бачите цей бедж як
зображення як
це можна
використовувати наприклад Чи роботодавці
знають як працюють ці
беджи Наприклад ми в закладі професійні
освіти
для механіків автомобільного сектору Ми
використовували ці беджі і ми говорили
роботодавцям що от на додачу до
звичайного
диплому учні або випускники можуть
додавати
беджі до своїх заяв це настільки ще таке
нове що вони ще не знають наскільки
можна
довіряти яка цінність є цієї системи і
тому потрібно тут забезпечувати що у
всей всей весь ланцюг
створення цінності розуміє це
Отже я розказав вам про ці відкриті
беджі і європейську рамку яку можна
використовувати для
цього Дякуємо еско за вашу презентацію і
такий системний підхід ми відтепер
знаємо більше про бедgс Тепер нарешті
дійшла черга до наших чудових партнерів
Міністерства освіти і науки перевага
Оста го виступу це те що він
запам'ятовується найкраще А що ж у нас
відбувається у сфері державної політики
щодо впровадження електронного навчання
в Україні і якими є плани на
майбутнє
Отже про це нам розкаже Анна Бондар
проектна менеджерка зміст дистанційної
освіти команда підтримки відновлення та
реформ МОН України Анно будь ласка
Вітаю шановна
аудиторія шановні наші партнери а Дякую
за надану можливість мені долучитися до
такого заходу який ви сьогодні
організували і
провели власне на тему щодо використання
цифрових інструментів у системі
оцінювання та сертифікації при
розробленні
навчальних онлайні мене звати Анна
Бондар я проектна менеджерка зміст яка
відповідає за зміст дистанційної освіти
в команді підтримки відновлення та
реформ Міністерства освіти і науки
України Скажіть буд ласка колеги як мене
чутно все
добре Зараз чутно
добре Трошки пропадав звук зараз дуже
добре чутно я прошу вибачення
оскільки оскільки є У нас тут трішки
проблеми із
інтернетзв'язком от сподіваюся що це не
не стане
перешкодою для нашої
зустрічі Отже
а-а А ми взагалі сьогодні зустрілися і
розуміємо про те що в Україні незважаючи
на е цю повномасштабну війну яка
сьогодні Стосується кожного у нас
стрімко розвивається і стається цифрова
трансформація так І власне Міністерство
освіти і науки цьому активно
сприяє
саме в плані покращення доступності
освіти навіть в тих умовах в яких ми
сьогодні з вами знаходимося так і вже
відповідно задля
забезпечення освіти
проведення навчального процесу в
закладах от власне наші педагоги також
не мають уже іншого виходу аніж активно
навчатися самонавчатися розвиватися і
підвищувати свою цифрову грамотність
Оскільки ми всі розуміємо що ці умови
які сьогодні у нас Вони сприяють цьому і
для того щоб проводити навчальний процес
наші педагоги використовують різні різні
форми навчання
от але здебільшого це відбувається в
онлайн-форматі і в принципі на
деяких в деяких навчальних закладах це
відбувається саме в змішаному форматі
коли є можливість зустрічатися очно в
аудиторіях але саме ефект навчання
підсилюється Також через різні
онлайн-платформи через різні зустрічі на
різних платформах таких як Google Meet
таких як Zoom І власне кажучи це
говорить про те що цифрова грамотність
наших педагогів розвивається
Я хочу сьогодні вам наголосити про те що
Міністерство освіти задля
провадження професійної освіти в Україні
в цих
умовах і передували цим умовам саме
ковідні наші часи коли
був карантин так власне відбулось те що
на сьогодні у нас існує платформа
дистанційного навчання під назвою
професійна освіта та онлайн ви бачите
qr-код який ви можете зараз відсканувати
в своїх телефонах і вас автоматично пере
перекине на е платформу е Я впевнена що
більшість з ваш з вас уже знайомі з цією
платформою оскільки про це говорить саме
активність відвідувачів та реєстрація
користувачів на платформі Отже але
хочеться ще раз акцентувати вашу увагу
на те що власне ця платформа перш за все
покликана для того щоб до
допомогти педагогам і далі навчати
здобувачів освіти в тих умовах в яких ми
сьогодні з
вами Так поїхали Отже професійна освіта
онлайн ми знаємо що ви зараз дуже Всі
цифрово-грамотно так що я вам дуже дякую
і ви бачите знову ж таки qr-код можете
за ним доєднатися і власне ми бачимо і
моніторимо вашу активність через те що
від початку запуску нашої платформи А це
сталося 20 3 грудня 2022 року Так саме в
період таких тотальних блекаутів от
власне ми починали з дуже такої мізерної
кількості наших курсів це було
всього-навсього 24 онлайн-курси у нас на
платформі але це сталося презентація
відбулась презентація
і запуск платформи також на сьогодні
власне активність відвідувачів на
платформі становить понад 13 000 зараз
на платформі розміщено понад 100
онлайн-курсів в 32-х категоріях
а власне з метою якою була створена
платформа Я уже вам говорила повторюся
це власне підтримка учнів закладів
професійної освіти задля їхнього
навчання підтримка педагогічних
працівників які прагнуть підвищення
своєї кваліфікації підтримка
педагогічних працівників саме в плані
забезпечення додатковими сучасними
онлайнматеріалами і
також власне ця платформа покликана
задля
забезпечення навчанням усіх бажаючих в
рамках навчання впродовж всього життя а
саме як функціонує платформа професійна
професійна освіта онлайн Е то учні
можуть на ній ее реєструватися так і
педагоги-вчителі учні реєструються
переглядають і знаходять доступні
онлайн-курси на платформі також можуть
переглядати зміст курсу записуються на
навчання здобувають знання виконують
завдання для оцінювання і формують свій
рейтинг із можливістю весь час його
покращувати педагоги також реєструються
на платформі відповідно того як це
роблять учні також отримують доступ
до такого модулю який називається мій
кабінет задля впровадження своєї
діяльності педагога на платформі так е
також педагог на платформі може
проводити навчання на обраних курсах
запрошувати учнів корист чів бачити
статистику успішності керувати журналом
оцінок та модерувати дискусії
а отже на сьогодні на платформі
професійна освіта онлайн представлено 32
категорії за такими професіями
як
наприклад опоряджувальник будівельний
кухар кондитер агент з організації
туризму так професії стосуються таких
галузей як будівництва металообробки
деревообробки агросфери та інших
а
власне Ми дуже дякуємо нашим партнерам
які нам люб'язно надають свої онлайн
матеріали онлайн-курси які проходять
адаптацію
[музика]
і переносяться до нас на платформу
власне оцей от досвід наших іноземних
партнерів Він саме в цьому для нас є
безцінним тому що ви всі практики і ви
знаєте як складно взагалі в
дистанційному форматі чогось навчити
здобувача освіти в закладі
професійно-технічної освіти Так але
власне досвід цей якраз нас вчить тому
що можна робити онлайн-контент саме
практикоорієнтовним тобто робити його
максимально таким зручним для того щоб
поєднувати оцей от змішаний якраз формат
навчання які зараз типи освітніх
матеріалів у нас розміщені на платформі
це перший тип такий як лекційні
матеріали з визначних з з визначенням
технологічних різних термінів понять
наявністю ілюстрацій схем та також
посиланнями на корисні матеріали за
професіями і Також у нас є більш
складніші такі онлайн-курси і вони собою
представляють е
контент такий от як модулі до освітніх
програм вони відповідають результатам
навчання стандартам освіти
також вони мають дуже високий рівень
інтерактивності різні інтерактивні
презентації 3dмоделі симулятори з
доповненою реальністю та інше А власне
також на сьогодні у нас на платформі
професійна освіта онлайн активізована
така функція як видача
сертифікатів тому що ми до цього йшли
довго і
це говорить про те що ми за завжди
готові розвиватися і ми прагнемо ставати
кращими і на сьогодні уже на платформі у
нас розміщено 17 сертифікаційних
онлайн-курсів короткотермінових саме які
нам надали е наші партнери фінські
партнери в рамках проекті проекту fo
Skills і два тренінги
онлайн-тренінги для керівників закладів
професійно-технічної освіти та педагогів
от власне 17 сертифікаційних
онлайн-курсів які зараз у нас на
платформі розміщуються в категоріях
охорона здоров'я соціально-психологічна
робота інформаційно-комунікаційні
технології будівництво підприємництво та
менеджмент а власне
а вони всі уже активні знаходяться на
платформі тому будь ласка ви можете
заходити
дивитися проходити навчання і також
активно використовувати у своїй
педагогічній діяльності у своїй роботі
які на сьогодні перед нами стоять задачі
от власне на платформі професійна освіта
онлайн це перш за все редизайн
платформи Також ми плануємо розробити і
активізувати систему каталогів та пошуку
онлайн-курсів освітніх матеріалів на
платформі професійна освіта онлайн і
також враховуємо виклики які сьогодні
стоять перед нами це обов'язково про те
що щоб забезпечити людей з обмеженими
фізичними можливостями також користува
користуватися тими освітніми матеріалами
які у нас розміщуються на платформі Саме
через покращення інклюзивності платформи
професійна освіта онлайн е Я сподіваюся
що це нам вдасться швидко е всі ці наші
виклики е подолати і покращити
функціонування платформи професійна
освіта онлайн Ну а вас Власне кажучи ми
просимо залишатися з нами долучати своїх
учнів до того щоб вони знайомилися з
тими освітніми матеріалами які у нас є
на платформі тому що насправді за кожним
онлайн-курсом стоїть надзвичайно
величезна робота е робота команд за
кожною професією оскільки повторюся ще
раз це дуже нелегка задача зробити ті
освітні матеріалами практикоорієнтовним
І власне так щоб вони лягали в той
освітній процес який здійснюється зараз
в закладах
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
тому я вас прошу залишайтеся з нами
допомагайте нам ставати кращими і я
сподіваюся що в недалекій перспективі
кожен педагог який відчуває в собі от
потенціал щодо розроблення
онлайнконтенту зможе це зробити в
середовищі нашої платформи професійного
освіта онлайн Дякую всім е за час за
вашу увагу Вибачте за технічні
незручності але це ще раз говорить про е
знаєте про готовність допомогти і про
відчуття такої от великої команди єдиної
тому Дякую всім бажаю безпечного дня і
успіхів Дякую Анно Дуже вам за
презентацію І дуже цікавий саме
демонстрація
такої системності у розміщенні
матеріалів на платформі дуже цікаві ви
продемонстрували категорії розміщення це
дуже важливо і це дуже зручно для
користувачів ось А ми зараз переходимо
До сесії питань відповідей на жаль в нас
залишається Вже небагато часу і тому
Спочатку ми зачитаємо питання які
надійшли в чат і потім можливо одне-два
Питання якщо зали час
буде від учасників я буду називати
заклад і
прізвище відповідно до піднятої руки в
чаті будемо робити це по черзі поважаючи
один одного Отже перше питання яке тут в
нас насправді тут не одне питання а
одразу Я так зрозуміла два
питання хвилиночку Ми
[музика]
дивимось так так знайшла я на жаль не
можу
ідентифікувати хто задав питання
А значить це питання до Анни Лагер та
Петрі щодо я зачитую Закріплення
матеріалу під час
мікронавчання які форми оцінювання та
цифрові інструменти pedлеet mмітер
Google форми ваші
найулюбленіші і саме ви рекомендуєте
застосовувати це питання до Анни Лагер і
питання до Петрі
друге openedкs це безкоштовний сервіс
якщо ні скільки він коштує Дякую Аня
Лагер будь ласка ви відповідаєте
першою
я так Наскільки я зрозуміла це мова йде
про Закріплення матеріалу під час
мікронавчання
microlearning саме от для Закріплення
матеріалу які форми оцінювання та
цифрові
інструменти ви вважаєте
найбільш напевно ефективними чи
найкращими от з вашого
досвіду якщо йдеться про формативне
оцінювання то все що я презентувала це
саме ті інструменти які ми вже обрали із
сотні тобто все що в презентації це вже
рекомендується багато мають безкоштовну
підписку але мають можливо деякі
обмеження Скільки питань ви можете там
включити Але звичайно залежить від того
що ви хочете робити Я використовую сама
дуже багато падлів для співпраці
обговорення
ментіміти використовую Я бачу що там
було питання в чаті про тмітер
тіміitр також має безкоштовну підтрим
підписку
Але там є обмежена кількість
презентації якщо ви не плануєте
використовувати сотню різних презентацій
ви можете створити
дві і навіть безкоштовною підпискою Там
дуже багато
можливостей і можна проводити там
голосування ранжування збирати
статистику Я використовую mмітер падlт
багато і не не тільки я моя команда о ми
саме обрали ці
інструменти і
ну учасники
також їм дуже подобається і все нlн
також дуже хороший Тому що тут можна
візуалізувати можна
включати відео текстову інформацію тобто
залежно дійсно від мети
А яку роду співпрацю ви хочете навколо
якої теми як ви хочете залучати тобто
немає тут якоїсь універсальної
відповіді А питання щодо openex
а-е платформа Міністерства
грунтується на цій платформі Це відкрите
джерело безкоштовно ви можете
використовувати Але звичайно якщо ви
доєднуєте
додаткові інструменти розроблені третьою
стороною тут може бути певна плата але
ті інструменти які вже є в цій платформі
Open evex вони вони всі без
коштовни і якщо я можу тут додати навіть
інструменти третіх сторін як ми говорили
деякі все ще мають
ее безкоштовну
підписку ви можете там
створювати якісь елементи і потім
переносити їх в
openedex Я сподіваюсь що ви отримали
відповідь є наступне питання також щодо
вартості ліцензії вбрапол ну це таке
дуже специфічне питання Можливо хтось з
експертів знає це ось тому що вони вже
працюють з наявними інструментами але
якщо хтось знає щодо вартості то скажіть
будь
ласка
ну хочу сказати що Google форми і інші
безкоштовні
підписки Ну вони так само виконують Якщо
ви хочете провести більш широки
дослідження чи опитування то тоді
вебропол а для в педагогічних цілях є
безкоштовні інструменти і тут би я не
хвилювалася за ліцензію і вартість
ліцензії тому що weбпол - це саме для
досліджень Наприклад якщо ви
збираєте дані від учасників проводите
статистику тобто для звичайного
використання в педагогічних цілей
Зазвичай googleформ ми достатні але якщо
ви хочете проводити якесь більш широке
дослідження то тоді вже використовуйте
інший інструмент Дякую мамерві чи є ще
запитання чи ми будемо вже завершувати
наш
семінар Я поки що не бачу піднятих рук
Отже якщо будуть запитання Я думаю що ми
зможемо в такому
порядку це все з'ясувати і надіслати
відповіді Ну давайте тоді час ми трошки
вичерпали а і зайшли навіть але думаю що
це було корисно тобто Дякуємо партнерам
за всіляку підтримку і допомогу у
підготовці семінару Дякуємо всім
учасникі учасникам
А за те що ви відвідали наш семінар і
сподіваємось що він був корисним для вас
дав нові
ідеї нову інформацію про інтерактивні
інструменти і як їх можна застосувати
саме у вашій роботі е і Бажаю всім дуже
гарного дня ее успіхів і нам усім
Перемоги і чекаємо на наступні зустрічі
дуже Дякую
щиро дякую дуже
цікаве до побачення до побачення
побачення до побачення до побачення Дуже
дякую goodby Дякую до побачення дякую До
побачення
дякую